cette attaque intervient donc presque
deux semaines après l'assassinât de
samuel pâti à conflans sainte honorine
il il était alors question du symbole de
l'éducation aujourd'hui c'est l'église
qui est visé oui alors les rappelons
quand même que l'église a déjà été visée
avec le père mail avec avaient été
égorgées également donc c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau de nouveau
quand ce sont des journalistes on est
tous journalistes comme ce sont des
professeurs on est tous professeurs
comme ce sont des curés on est tous curé
puis demain ce sera un imam autre atout
si mal je crois qu'il faut maintenant le
temps je dirais de la tolérance de la de
la main tendue est terminé je pense que
la france n'a pas de leçons à recevoir
de tolérance de qui que ce soit et
encore moins des pays comme la turquie
donc il faut pas si dans une autre phase
maintenant ça fait 25 ans que la menace
islamiste terroriste islamiste endogène
et révélé sur notre territoire
jusqu'à présent il faut quand même noter
je dirai au profit de l'exécutif actuel
d'avoir été les premiers à mener un
combat contre l'idéologie
moi je dis depuis des années que je n'ai
aucun doute sur les capacités de nos
forces qu'elles soient police militaire
à faire face sur le plan opérationnel et
sur le plan purement sécuritaire en
revanche j'ai toujours eu des doutes sur
la solidité intellectuelle de nos de nos
élites et de nos politiques pour mener
un combat sur l'idéologie
or cette guerre contre caen contre
l'islamisme on la gagne ou on la perd
dans la dimension idéologique la guerre
contre l'islam l'islamisme pardon la
guerre contre l'islamisme contre
l'idéologie qui nourrit le terrorisme
islamiste en la mène depuis quelques
semaines avant ça on se contentait de
s'attaquer aux terroristes en action sur
porteurs d'armes mais ça c'est si c'est
pas du c'est pas du long terme m le long
terme ces deux lorsque vous êtes ce que
vous lorsque vous vous évoquez pardon
ces quelques semaines vous faites
référence aux réactions de l'exécutif
notamment dans la foulée d'une marque de
samuel pâtit on l'a vu ce volontarisme
affiché de la part de d'emmanuel mac
ronde de jean castex qui ont fait un
certain nombre d'annoncés sur ces
perquisitions menées dans la foulée de
l'assassinât du professeur d'histoire à
conflans-sainte-honorine
cette perquisition s'est fichée est-ce
aussi qu'ils sont sur le point d'être
expulsé un certain nombre d' annonce
pour revenir sur les fêtes de ce matin
est ce qu'il faut aussi façon très
concrète renforcer aussi la sécurité des
lieux de culte alors que
certaines cérémonies religieuses a en
l'occurrence elle est là la toussaint
seront célébrées ce week end
oui alors renforcer la sécurité
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on est au
maximum de ce qu'on peut demander à nos
forces de l'ordre pour autant ça va pas
dire qu'on ait plus de marge de
manoeuvre
on a encore une marge de manoeuvre il ya
quelque chose qui en france kéké pas
trop dans notre culture et qu'on a du
mal à faire c'est d'impliquer peut-être
plus fortement le privé le fameux
continuum jeu reprend les termes un
petit peu à la mode mais le côté minium
sécuritaire qui consiste à renforcer
l'engagement de l'état sur sur les
domaines qui sont vraiment régalien met
à faire de toute la chaîne de la
coproduction de sécurité et d'aller
jusqu'à l'implication du privé
quand on voit les moyens qui sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui sur la solitaire
on peut encore engagé des moyens
il ya des entreprises qui ont les moyens
de se protéger faut-il encore quelques
années le droit d'avoir des équipes en
armes par exemple la sueur c'est pas les
choses peuvent être parfaitement faire
avec fait avec le secteur privé en est
en total contrôle et en totale maîtrise
de l'état alors on en parle beaucoup
mais mais il n'y a pas grand chose
aujourd'hui de réellement mis en place à
ce que vous évoquez à l'instant cette
sécurité privée aujourd'hui l'état
français n'est pas capable de gérer
convenablement cette menace terroriste
elle est à fond si le gers dans ceux qui
aujourd'hui on est on est débordés si
vous voulez de comment vous voulez avoir
un policier l'a si on prend l'exemple de
nice et qui est excitant on a une
politique en à la première police
municipale de france
il faut relever également que cette
police municipale elle elle a pris la
place de la de la police de proximité
moi je trouve que c'est plutôt une bonne
chose donc de fait elles se retrouvent
prime aux intervenants donc elle doit
être en capacité aujourd'hui de faire
c'est qu'elle a très bien fini c'est à
dire d'intervenir très rapidement et de
neutraliser l'attaqué
donc ça nice c'est plutôt je dirais le
bon élève en france parce qu'il ya des
gros effectifs et la police et bien
formés bien équipé et c
il ya une énorme disparité donc il ya
déjà un travail à faire
les polices municipales c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit qu'on doit consolider
en termes de prérogatives mais aussi en
termes de formation et d'équipement mais
on doit aller plus loin il ya les lieux
de culte il ya des lieux de culte qui
pourrait très bien avoir une sécurité
privée on va pas pouvoir déployer
l'armée partout et encore une fois on a
besoin de déployer la police et l'armée
surdose sur d'autres sites donc là le le
fait que la police municipale soit
intervenu en premier c'est quand même
c'est quand même important il faut lui
folie faut le relever mais ça c'est pour
la réaction immédiate une fois que les
faits tragiques dramatiques se sont
produits
mais aujourd'hui il est question avant
tout d'aider moyens que l'on attribue
que l'on que l'on met dans le
renseignement et notamment peut-être
extérieur puisque c'est votre spécialité
pour empêcher cette menace terroriste
écoutez moi le jeu coin et là pour le
coup vous l'avez vous l'avais dit je
suis plutôt bien placé pour l'avoir
observé sur sur de nombreuses années
je pense que l'europe on peut toujours
pas fonctionné les renseignements et on
doit en bois le perfectionner la juste
et l'adapter à l'évolution de je dirais
de l'ennemi et de la menace mais je
crois que c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas le maillon faible si vous
voulez le renseignement alors en termes
de réponse sécuritaire policière
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre en place le
maillon faible il ya encore une fois
vous vous orientez sur sur la réponse
policière le maillon faible pour moi il
est politique c'est à dire que je disais
tout à l'heure que c'est la première
fois qu'on s'en prend réellement à
l'idéologie mais je faisais pas
référence aux déclarations des
déclarations enflammées et séduisant
temps en temps depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années mais maintenant il faut line
tout est lié en fait l'immigration
j'entendais votre votre intervenants
précédents monsieur paul m je m'inscris
complètement dans ce qu'il disait je
veux dire la réponse elle est forcément
global l'immigration maintenant
j'entendais julien dray sur un plateau
julien dray je veux dire qu'on ne peut
pas taxer de de fascisme julien dray qui
dit sur un plateau que lui il faisait
aujourd'hui sans état d'âme le lien
entre terrorisme islamiste et
immigration dont acte
allons-y maintenant faut refaire mon
petit peu les frontières filtrons
maîtrisant qui vient en tension d'autres
territoires on peut plus continuer à
faire leur être dans le déni comme on
l'est depuis depuis 25 ans alors vous
vous déclarez finalement que tout est
mise en place aujourd'hui pour répondre
à cette menace terroriste c'est avant
tout une question d'idéologie est ce que
dans l'intervention par exemple il ya
deux semaines deux de l'exécutif est ce
que vous avez le sentiment que dans la
foulée du meurtre de l'assassinât samuel
potier
alors je sais pas si vous aimez bien les
biens choisis mais peut-être renforcer
ou en tout cas accentuée avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui année ce sont deux
faits terroristes qui touchent à la
france
est-ce que la réponse de l'exécutif doit
être très forte qu'est ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous attendez ce que
emmanuel macron avec l'association
elle-même patier a tenté de répondre à
l'opinion commune en annonçant des
choses très fortes est ce qu'aujourd'hui
il doit aller encore plus loin
moi oui moi je ne me laisse plus du tout
grise et si vous voulez par les
déclarations fortes là je crois que
globalement les français il faut sortir
de nos déclarations un peu mièvre des
bougies de vous n'aurez pas ma haine etc
ça se croient que on tourne la page de
ça et c'est très bien ensuite on a le
degré au dessus c'est à dire des
déclarations comme vous disiez un peu
enflammé c'est bien mais plus personne
n'y croit
donc maintenant il sait des actions les
actions ça a commencé c'est à ça que je
faisais référence tout à l'heure comme
je disais qu'il faut noter que c'est et
je suis pas le meilleur défenseur de
l'exécutif actuel
politiquement je veux dire mais il faut
noter que les premières actions ont été
menées comme ton 10 ou des associations
comme barak à city quand on dit sous le
seuil est ce sont des actions concrètes
ce sont les premières c'est trop fébrile
à mon goût que deviennent ces gens là
c'est bien de laisser viennent de
dissoudre leur association
mais que deviennent ces gens là que
fait-on avec la ville de grenoble par
exemple
donc là on a un problème franco français
qui a confidences et le ccf
quand on voit des associations via des
associations u
ni terres désolées la haute finance
comme monsieur rose qui finance
également le ccf
on doit stopper ça on doit stopper cette
ingérence extérieure
encore une fois la france n'a aucune
leçon à recevoir ni de tolérance n'est
ni de droits de l'homme etc
on doit arrêter tout ça est et on doit
reprendre la main sur notre territoire
on doit expulser ces gens là certains
ont fait la demande de nazis de l'asile
politique en turquie très bien très bien
ils vont manquer à personne c'est à dire
facilitant leur la démarche et puis
qu'ils aillent vivre en turquie
enfin voilà ce que je dire à un moment
donné et ça c'est politique c'est pas
plus de policiers plusieurs jardins plus
de militaires nos policiers font le
travail
nos militaires font le travail ils ont
besoin d'être soutenus par les
politiques
quelquefois ils sont fébriles si
aujourd'hui la riposte elle est bien que
ça fait quand même beaucoup évolué mais
si la réponse est les quelques la
réponse je parle policière et militaire
elle est quelquefois un peu fébrile
c'est parce que l'opposition toujours
peur d'être remis en question notamment
dans l'encadrement de son système de
réponse l'état
la réponse allait politique notre
appareil sécuritaire et on peut le
perfectionner et il faut le
perfectionner et on va l'adapter on a
affaire à des gens engagés profondément
républicain d'autres policiers les
gérards j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur ces
sujets là à l'étranger je peux vous dire
que ce qu'on vient de voir là à nice
avec un terroriste qui viennent faire
trois morts et qui est soigné par le
propre force d'intervention qui est pas
tuer et qui soit mais ça n'existe nulle
part ailleurs mais ça n'existe nulle
part ailleurs je dire partout le parc où
le terroriste il est mort voyez ce que
je veux dire donc maintenant ça suffit
il faut il faut vraiment qu'on change
intellectuellement psychologiquement
d'attitude et vous voulez avec moi